المعارك العنيفه مستمره في مدينه بخموت
وفي محيطها والقوات الروسيه تتابع قصفها
بالمدفعيه في محاوله للاستيلاء على هذه
المدينه قبل حلول الذكرى الاولى لبدايه ما
تعتبرها عمليه عسكريه خاصه في اوكرانيا
بعد النكسات العسكريه التي مرت بها القوات
الاوكرانيه تتابع من جهتها دفاعها عن هذا
الحصن ببساله كما استطاعت اسقاط 18 صاروخا
روسيا من اصل 36 استهدف بعضها اكبر مصفاه
نفط في البلاد اعاقه اجتماعنا اليوم مع
جميع قاده مناطق العمليه وسمعنا منهم
بالتفصيل عن الوضع الميداني في كل منطقه
وعن افاقها حول امدادات الاسلحه وامدادات
الذخيره وتدريب قواتنا العسكريه وخطط
العدو وقدراته وامكانيه الرد الاوكراني
والمضي قدما لتحرير المزيد من ارضنا وهي
اولويه نحضرها بعنايه قائد مجموعه فاجنر
المسلحه الروسيه اف جيني بريكوجين توقع
السيطره على بخموت في اذار مارس او نيسان
ابريل المقبل عازيا البطء في التقدم الى
البيروقراطيه العسكريه الروسيه هناك حاجه
الى بخموت لشل الجيش الاوكراني تماما
العدو يبدي جاهزيه جيده التقدم لا يسير
بسرعه التي نتمناها اعتقد اننا كنا سناخذ
بخموت قبل حلول العام الجديد لولا
بيروقراطيتنا العسكريه الرهيبه التي تضع
العصي في العجلات وهو ما يؤخر تقدمنا قتل
عدد من المدنيين واصيب مدنيون اخرون بجروح
نتيجه القصف الروسي على مدينه بخموت يوم
الخميس حسب مكتب المدعي العام الاوكراني